now there's two of you there someone's
got the deck of cards and you can see
for this one here I've actually already
begun shuffling it um I will do a bit
more shuffling because when someone
comes to you with a deck of playing
cards you should never ever trust them
okay like just always be suspicious okay
in fact I'll go on better I'll take off
my watch uh so you know I'm not hiding
up anything on my sleeves okay they're
already pre-rolled up okay so once
you've shuffled your own deck of cards
and put away those jokers in there as
well can you just hold up your deck of
cards to me so I know that you're good
to go and maybe just kind of fan it out
like I have so that you can see and so
that I can see it's nice and mixed up
that looks good others can someone show
me their Deco cards I can hear someone
fancy riffling their cards good for them
could you hold them up so that I can see
them I I'd love to see if you yeah
that's that looks good I'm still waiting
on a few more okay that's really
shuffled up the front here we can see
that's what we call a casino wash when
you put on the table and you do this uh
that's what they do at casinos they it
looks like they washing right anyway
okay okay
now
okay so for this next part one of you
has all the cards in their hand and the
other person is going to be the person
the trick is performed on we're about to
do a card trick in case you hadn't
worked that out okay now because I'm
alone I'm going to need your help in a
minute to pick a card and do all this
kind of thing okay but person who's got
the cards all right you've got them all
in your hand what I'd like you to do is
to hold them like I'm holding them so
that your partner can choose a card any
card so go ahead let them pick a
card okay now what I'm going to do I
need your help here for this part right
um I don't have a partner here in front
of me so I'm going to pretend as if I do
you're all of you are my partner okay so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to on
your behalf select a card please watch
me closely so you know I'm not looking
at the card I'm not looking at it okay
so there it is on the table and what I'm
going to do is just for for a moment so
that you all know what this card is I am
going to turn it over so you can all see
but I'm going to do that while covering
my eyes so you know I don't know what it
is this this make sense this is as if
like there's a partner I have here okay
so here here's the card all right I'm
taking off my glasses so you know I'm
suitably blind in fact I'm put them like
here okay cover are you content I can't
see anything yes come on are you content
I can't see anything okay thank you
that's great so here's the card okay now
please don't say it aloud obviously
because then I know what it is please
commit it to
memory because this trick will be much
less impressive if I get to the end and
then you're like and I'll say is this
this your card and then you're like I
can't remember okay so are you content
you've all seen it yes okay great I'm
going to turn it back over now okay is
it is it turned back over can I open my
eyes okay wonderful all right so here's
your mystery card okay now have you let
your partner choose a mystery card do
they have their own Mystery card now yes
thumbs up okay amazing so now person
with the cards here's what I'd like you
to do please deal out two piles in front
of you of 15 cards 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 there's one pile and then
you can do it again I like to do it in
threes sometimes cuz they're quite easy
to count two threes
33s 4 threes and then 5 threes okay and
then last lastly person with the cards
you should have a whole bunch of cards
left in your hand can I ask you to look
at those
cards and I'd like you to see if you can
find I've got one but it depends on how
you've gone I'd like you to find a card
that looks like a Jack now there are
four jacks in the deck so I'm hoping
you've got at least one in those
leftover cards if you don't have one
tell me if you don't have one do anyone
not able to find it hold up your hand if
you can find a Jack in fact hold up your
jack for me so that I can see the Jack
okay good good good mostly we're there
okay fantastic so take that Jack if
you've got it there and you can put it
down you know what if you can't find a
Jack don't stress just pretend that
whatever card you want is a jack but the
rest of us we have a jack okay you'll
see why that's
important
okay so now this is what your table
should look like okay here is this
mystery card and then I'll make a bit
more space there we go then you've got
two piles of 15 one of them is going to
belong to the person who selected the
mystery card and then one of them is
going to belong to the person with the
Jack okay so this is what it looks like
on my table maybe you should have this
facing each other
okay now for all of you I would now like
the person who selected the card right
the person who's not performing the TR I
want you to have a lot of power in this
next stage okay so see these two piles
of 15 watch closely what I'm going to
ask you to do is to divide that pile up
here's one pile of 15 right divide it
into two piles of whatever size you like
so this is not the person performing the
trick it's the person who picked the
mystery card okay divide it into two and
then take this other pile and also
divide it into two obviously because
there's 15 you can't actually divide the
cards in half why not because it's an
it's an odd number so the closest you
could get is like seven cards and eight
cards I'm not even looking at how many
I've got but they're divided roughly
into two groups okay here we go
person who chose the mystery card could
you raise your hand for me I just want
to know who I'm making eye contact with
okay fantastic you're in control of this
next part right you're going to bury
your mystery card in the deck here's the
way you're going to do it okay you're
going to this is uh from your
perspective right you've got your
original pile of 15 and it's been split
right I want you to put your mystery
card on top of and you can choose one of
these piles okay so I'm going to put it
on this one okay then you've got the
other two piles you can choose mystery
person you can choose one of them to go
on top now I've got a left and a right I
should have asked it the first time
would you guys like me to do the left or
the right right I heard left first I
heard I heard both but I heard left
first so here's the left pile what I'm
going to do is I'm going to put it on
top so the mystery card is buried inside
here okay now remember how I asked you
to find a Jack Jack so this is Jack the
hunter Jack the hunter is going to find
where the card is we're going to hide
Jack the hunter in the deck as well so
in the same way that we hid the mystery
card in here we're going to hide Jack
the hunter between this is the one
closer to you between this card this
pile and this pile so the mystery card's
somewhere in here Jack is somewhere in
here and now we're going to combine the
piles together just put one pile on top
of the other and now you've got all the
cards okay now so far you've just been
following what I've been doing okay I
want you to stop for a moment and just
look at what's happening on screen I
want you to follow and see this step and
then you guys are all going to have your
turn okay Jack the hunter there's Jack
is going to hunt down that card that I
closed my eyes I I don't know what it is
but you guys all saw it on screen right
here's the way it's going to work and
you're going to do this too I'm going to
deal out all the cards one by one into
two piles like this I'm going left
right left right and I'm going to do
this for the entire pile okay I'll speed
up a little bit because you can see what
I'm doing right so I'm splitting the
pile into
two and once I've done that you can see
maybe you can see this is why it's face
up there's Jack the hunter right there
see Jack Jack is telling me that your
card is in this PA so I'm going to get
rid of all these other ones okay and
then I do it again I'll do it faster
because I think you get the idea right I
deal them all
out watch closely and then Jack the
hunter is going to tell me where your
card is according to jack your card is
in this pile so I'll get rid of the rest
I'm getting close now so here goes two
piles Jack the hunter is narrowing in on
which card he thinks is yours I've only
got a few left now one 2 3
four Jack the hunter is telling me that
this is your card so can you please tell
me
we here we go Jack was
right not bad right now now I'm so
delighted you enjoyed that but it's so
much better watching compared to
watching someone else do magic is when
you do magic yourself so all of you have
the same thing I had in my hands
remember what we were doing was I'll
just rehearse it right you're dealing it
into two decks alternating one at a time
and look for where Jack ends up Jack is
hunting down the Carden at the end he'll
find it good luck off you go